[Música]
[Aplausos]
en el año 2013 un niño de tan sólo 12
años cayó desvanecido en el patio de su
escuela mientras jugaba con sus
compañeros
cuando punto cayó fue muy tarde cuando
lo encontraron los maestros y compañeros
al llegar intentaron reanimarlo los
paramédicos al intentar reanimarlo
ya no pudieron afortunadamente ponchó un
niño de tan sólo 12 años había muerto la
causa que dio el patólogo fue que ponchó
había tenido una obstrucción de las
arterias y ponchó había muerto de un
infarto agudo de miocardio como era
posible que un niño de tan sólo 12 años
pudiera morir de una enfermedad que
consideramos que es de personas adultas
este caso en particular llama mucho la
atención y me hizo preguntarme si el
caso de poncho era solamente un caso
aislado hoy vamos a empezar a ver
nuestro país más casos como el de este
niño
desafortunadamente no estamos viviendo
en la primera generación que
probablemente vivamos menos años que
nuestros padres así como menos años de
vida saludable que ellos
esto debido a una epidemia que tenemos
hoy en día y que muchos de nosotros no
estamos viendo méxico es el primer lugar
en obesidad infantil tenemos el primer
lugar en todo el mundo y hace unos años
le ganamos eeuu y seguimos así vamos a
ver muchos casos más como los de poncho
está demostrado se ha visto en muertes
accidentales de niños entre 4 y 14 años
que ya desde esa edad la grasa se
empieza a acumular en las arterias para
cuando tenemos 20 ó 30 años esas grasas
comienzan a formarse como placas y para
cuando tengamos 40 esas placas van a
comenzar a matarnos por eso la
importancia de hacer un cambio en lo que
está sucediendo en este momento en
nuestro país
muchas veces me preguntan si los
infartos son solamente una consecuencia
de envejecer finalmente todos decimos
que de algo tenemos que morir y muchas
veces decimos que el infarto va a ser
una causa normal porque nuestros padres
murieron de ella y porque la edad nos va
a llevar a tener un infarto
pero la respuesta es que no y la
respuesta la tenemos aquí mismo en
nuestro país
en la sierra de chihuahua existe una
comunidad que probablemente ustedes
conocen la comunidad tarahumara también
llamada los rarámuris que significa pies
ligeros esta comunidad ha llamado mucho
la atención a los científicos y a la
población en general debido a que es una
comunidad que tiene una alta capacidad
de ejercicio tiene una alta resistencia
física y más que nada lo que se dieron
cuenta es que con los tarahumaras en esa
comunidad los infartos del corazón no
existían eran prácticamente inexistentes
así como también se dieron cuenta que
esta comunidad no tenía antecedentes de
hipertensión y obesidad de diabetes se
empezaron a preguntar por qué en el año
2017 maría lorena ramírez fue conocida
en todo el mundo porque ganó el
ultramaratón y se hizo famosa porque lo
corrió con su vestimenta típica de los
rarámuris ella decidió correr en
chanclas y sandalias y no utilizar
equipo a pesar de que el ave no percibe
utilizar zapatos de marca
cuando le preguntaron cuál era su
secreto que creen que respondió
no como frijoles fue el secreto de ella
yo mismo el año pasado acudí como
voluntario a un pueblo que se llama
hablo galiana en la comunidad de chiapas
y yo iba con todas las ganas de atender
a la población porque ahí no hay médicos
y me dije a mí mismo voy a ver todas las
enfermedades que veo aquí en mi entorno
nos llevamos medicamentos para la
diabetes medicamentos para hipertensión
y así como esos medicamentos subieron en
mi maleta esos medicamentos regresaron
conmigo sorprendentemente en la semana
que estuvimos en esta comunidad no
encontré ningún paciente que haya tenido
un infarto en previos así como
familiares de ellos tampoco habían
tenido infartos
si acaso vimos algunos casos de presión
alta y de diabetes pero no era lo común
como vemos aquí en nuestra población
me pregunte cuál era el patrón común en
testa de dos comunidades el patrón común
es la dieta la comunidad traumada el 80%
de su ingesta de alimentos esta base de
plantas sus alimentos principales son el
maíz el frijol y la calabaza
la comunidad satánica con la que estuve
conviviendo el principal ingesta de
alimento que tiene es maíz y fríjol
ocasionalmente consumen algo de grasas
de origen animal y ocasionalmente
consumen pero no es lo típico
nosotros vivimos en una sociedad
consumista y no sólo en lo material todo
lo que queremos obtener de alimentos lo
podemos obtener en este momento y la
realidad es que en esta comunidad en
nuestra ciudad tenemos una ingesta alta
en carbohidratos refinados en alimentos
que vienen de grasa de origen animal si
no hacemos algo y ponemos atención en lo
que estamos viviendo la realidad va a
ser como la que vimos con ponchó cada
vez vamos a ver más personas jóvenes
morir de causas del corazón
ya en los años 40 unos científicos
estadounidenses se dieron cuenta cuando
estuvieron en uganda que en uganda no
existían los infartos las personas
morían de otras causas se preguntaron
por qué mientras que en eeuu en los años
40 la epidemia de infartos iba en
aumento
decidieron realizar un experimento
tomaron 632 autopsias de eeuu y 632
autopsias de uganda cual creen que fue
el resultado
132 autopsias de las américas de los
norteamericanos habían muerto por
infarto y de todos los 632 grandes
solamente uno había muerto de causas de
obstrucción de las arterias del corazón
otra vez nuevamente el vínculo entre dos
comunidades que vivían de forma
diferente los resultados que eran
obtenidos
pero como el entorno en sí es
responsable de nuestras enfermedades o
las decisiones que tomamos nos llevan a
tenerlas la respuesta está en una
ciencia muy interesante llamada la
epigenética
para explicar la epigenética básicamente
todo nuestro adn está compuesto de genes
estos genes tienen la capacidad de
prenderse o apagarse a lo largo de
nuestra vida el entorno es responsable
de que estos genes se prendan y se
apaguen muchos sabemos en este momento
de nuestras vidas que por ejemplo fumar
es malo y el fumar activa ciertos genes
que finalmente terminan desarrollando
tumores pero no solamente el fumar al té
aprende de estos genes hay muchas
situaciones que no hubieron aquí entre
ellos por ejemplo la dieta el ejercicio
el estrés las infecciones todo nuestro
entorno va a definir qué genes se
prenden y qué genes se apagan y esto va
a definir quiénes somos nosotros y cómo
queremos vivir aquí en adelante
el mejor ejemplo que tengo para explicar
la epigenética y el que más me gusta a
mí es el de las abejas
la abeja reina y la dejo obrera
comparten básicamente el mismo adn son
clones una de otra no son diferentes
ustedes saben cuál es la diferencia y
por qué una abeja se puede la reina en
una bajada de la obrera
la abeja reina tiene mayor tamaño casi
el doble una vez obrera la abeja reina
además tiene capacidad reproductiva y la
abeja reina vive mucho más que una vez
obrera la abeja reina vive
aproximadamente tres años y medio
mientras que lo deja obrera solamente
tiene una vida de tres años
cuando una oveja reina va a morir la
oveja obrera selecciona una larva y la
comienza a alimentar única y
exclusivamente de jalea real
con solamente consumir jalea real la
cual tiene unas enzimas que hace que esa
larva prenda ciertos genes para producir
proteínas que finalmente la vuelven la
abeja reina' esa es la única diferencia
entre una abeja reina y una abeja obrera
la dieta y aquí en este pequeño ejemplo
podemos ver el resultado de como el
entorno puede definir quién les vamos a
hacer en nuestra vida
también se ha visto en gemelos idénticos
que comparten el mismo adn cuando son
separados al nacer cada uno de ellos
puede desarrollar diferentes
enfermedades en su vida también cuando
toman diferentes decisiones esto nos
habla que no solamente nuestros genes
son los responsables de las enfermedades
que vamos a tener compartimos la mitad
de genes de nuestro papá y la mitad de
nuestra mama y no necesariamente porque
alguno de ellos haya muerto de un
infarto o de enfermedades
crónico-degenerativas nosotros tenemos
que tenerlas por verse
desafortunadamente en mi escuela y en la
mayoría de las escuelas de medicinas en
el país a los médicos no nos enseñan
sobre nutrición no nos enseñan sobre
prevención nos enseñan a tratar la
enfermedad una vez que ya está
establecida nos enseñará qué
medicamentos vamos a dar para
sobrellevar a estas enfermedades a lo
largo de nuestra vida si las escuelas de
medicina pusieran más atención en la
prevención tal vez otra cosa sería no
solamente de este país sino en todo el
mundo
y una de las preguntas que yo durante mi
formación en cardiología me he
preguntado es si una vez que las
arterias que están tapadas podemos hacer
que estas arterias se destapen hasta el
momento casi ningún medicamento ha
logrado hacer eso la mayoría de los
medicamentos lo que hacen sobrellevar la
enfermedad y alargar nos un poco nuestra
vida saludable
sin embargo un grupo de médicos
científicos decidieron experimentar con
dos grupos de personas que ya tenían las
arterias obstruidas y que decidieron
entrar a este experimento
se pararon dos grupos un grupo que
decidió entrar a un programa que de
cambios radicales al estilo de vida y
otro grupo que decidió solamente llevar
su tratamiento convencional y vigilancia
a cinco años
al grupo el que decidieron meternos a un
cambio radical al estilo de vida les
cambiaron principalmente su dieta les
dieron una dieta que era básicamente
crudivegana la dieta solamente podían
obtener las grasas de dietas de origen
vegetal les ofrecieron ejercicio
aeróbico moderado 30 minutos al día
resistieron suspender el tabaquismo
porque cuando empezaron el programa
todavía algunos fumaban
y los metieron en grupos de apoyo
durante cinco años les dijeron que
tenían que evitar por supuesto el
consumo de azúcar consumir carbohidratos
complejos y aumentar los alimentos
integrales que creen que pasó con este
grupo en el primer año 91% de ellos ya
no tenían dolor del pecho esto ya para
empezar les impresionó mucho a los
investigadores además la obstrucción de
las arterias había reducido casi un 2%
solamente con cambios del estilo de vida
a los cinco años 72% ya no tenían dolor
y la obstrucción se había reducido casi
un 4%
mientras que el grupo control
además el colesterol había reducido en
este grupo sin el uso de medicamentos y
habían perdido aproximadamente 10 kilos
mientras que el grupo control evolucionó
de forma natural las arterias se
obstruyeron aproximadamente un 3% en el
primer año y aproximadamente 12% en los
siguientes años además el grupo control
tuvo el doble de enfermedades tuvo el
doble de muertes el doble de infartos en
el transcurso de estos años
todos los seres humanos
en nuestro adn se encuentra la
importancia de las enfermedades que
vamos a desarrollar y la dieta no
solamente es importante para prevenir
infartos agudos al miocardio la dieta
también está involucrada en la forma en
la que vamos a envejecer a lo largo de
nuestra vida
en todos nuestros cromosomas en la
última parte en la punta de ellos existe
una estructura que se llama telómeros
los telómeros es como si fuera la punta
de una cinta de zapatos protege nuestro
adn de que se desgasten sin embargo con
el paso del tiempo cada vez que una
célula se divide esos telómeros empiezan
en un ángulo
a cortar con el paso de los años
esos telómeros se acortan tanto que
finalmente la célula muere cuando el
telómeros se va acortando nosotros vamos
envejeciendo se vio que los telómeros
eran el vínculo entre la edad y la
enfermedad
sin embargo en california existe este
árbol que es el árbol matusalén este
árbol tiene cuatro mil ochocientos años
y es el árbol más viejo de todo el mundo
este árbol e incluso estaba aquí antes
de que se hicieran las pirámides de
egipto se preguntaron cómo era posible
que un ser vivo tuviera la capacidad de
tener una vida tan prolongada
encontraron que sus telómeros se
encontraban casi intactos y cuando
empezaron a estudiarlo descubrieron que
este árbol tenía una enzima que se
llamaba telomerasa la telomerasa así ya
que estos telómeros no se encogieran de
forma normal afortunadamente para
nosotros también encontraron que los de
la telomerasa se encontraban los humanos
y se preguntaron si podíamos acortar el
encogimiento de los telómeros nuevamente
un grupo de científicos con esta
pregunta decidió escoger un grupo de
pacientes que tenían cáncer de próstata
les dijeron nos vamos a meter en los
grupos uno de ellos quisieron entrar un
grupo de cambios del estilo de vida de
forma radical nuevamente mientras que el
otro grupo se quedó solamente en
vigilancia a lo largo de cinco años
nuevamente las intervenciones que
hicieron fueron muy similares se
enfocaron en en una dieta que era
básicamente de origen vegetal era una
dieta donde le dieron proteínas que
venían a base de plantas granos sin
refinar legumbres y menos del 10% de
toda su ingesta podría venir de podría
venir de grasas y calorías y calorías de
carbohidratos refinados
además los pusieron a hacer ejercicio
los metieron en grupos de apoyo a lo
largo de cinco años y les enseñaron a
usar el manejo del estrés nos metieron a
clases de yoga les enseñaron a respirar
les enseñaron a relajarse y
tranquilizarse lo largo de cinco años
cuando vieron los resultados se
sorprendieron no esperaba que fueran tan
significativos
el cuadro que ven aquí azul de hecho son
la longitud de los telómeros no
solamente no se habían encogido de forma
normal sino que en algunos de ellos
habían aumentado de tamaño mientras que
el grupo control de los telómeros se
habían encogido de forma normal como
probablemente se vayan encogiendo en
todos nosotros a lo largo de nuestra
vida
no vengo aquí a decirles que se vuelvan
vegetarianos porque yo no lo soy no es
fácil cambiar es cambiar su estilo de
vida pero si es mi deber informarles la
evidencia que existe y los estudios que
se han elección al pasado para que en
este momento con esta plática quede en
su conciencia que van a decidir hacer a
lo largo de su vida hay siete factores
que tienen que recordar siete factores
que pueden prevenir infartos tenemos dos
factores mecánicos que son la presión
alta y la obesidad
tenemos dos factores químicos que son
las grasas altas y la diabetes que es el
azúcar alto en la sangre y tenemos tres
factores de conducta fuma si no fumas
haces ejercicio no haces ejercicio y
comes mal cuando digo comer mal es
llevar una dieta alta en grasas de
origen animal altas en carbohidratos
simples como refrescos hamburguesas y
mucho de lo que estamos acostumbrados en
nuestra población
si no hacemos algo la persona que más
quiere es la que está en este momento al
lado de ti va a morir desafortunadamente
de un infarto según las estadísticas en
mexico es la causa número uno y no
podemos evitar en este momento si no
hacemos cambios en el estilo de vida que
esto siga haciendo de esa manera si nos
enfocáramos en un mundo donde nos
enfocáramos más en que comemos y menos
en qué medicamentos vamos a tomar otra
cosa sería imaginen un mundo donde no
necesitáramos pastillas porque la
mayoría de las enfermedades las
pudiéramos prevenir es difícil pero hay
que llevar un paso a la vez y es mejor
hacerlo en compañía de sus seres
queridos se ha visto que cuando queremos
hacer cambios si los hacemos con otra
persona es mucho más sencillo de
lograrlo
que la comida sea tu alimento y el
alimento sea tu medicina muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]